AHH!
- AHH!
OMEGA PI OMEGA!
- OMEGA PI OMEGA!
- [barking]
OMEGA PI OMEGA!
- OMEGA PI OMEGA!
- YEAH!
- YO, BRAND ME, SON.
- YEAH.
- BRAND ME,
DO IT ON MY CHEST.
- YEAH.
- STRAIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE, SON.
- YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
- AHH!
- YEAH, SON!
- OH, YEAH--YO...
YO, YO, HOLD UP, MAN.
COME ON, WAIT.
WAIT, WAIT, THAT'S...
THAT [bleep]
IS UPSIDE-DOWN, SON.
IT--IT'S TO THE SIDE
A LITTLE BIT TOO.
- OH, [bleep], WELL, OKAY,
MY--MY BAD, DOG.
MY BAD, DOG. YOU WANNA
KEEP DOING THIS [bleep]?
LET'S GO!
- YEAH, MAN.
I'M JUST--I'M SAYING,
YO, BE CAREFUL.
- I GOT YOU, DOG,
I GOT YOU...YEAH!
- AHH!
- WHAT'S UP?
THAT'S WHAT'S UP!
- YEAH.
- STRAIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE, SON!
- YOU CAN'T GO BACK
MIDDLE NOW, SON.
- WHAT?
- WE ALREADY COMMITTED
TO THE UPSIDE-DOWN
AND TO THE SIDE.
- I GOT YOU, DOG, YEAH!
- AHH!
WHAT ARE YOU
DOING, MAN?
- YOU SAID UPSIDE-DOWN
AND TO THE SIDE.
- THAT'S THREE OMEGAS!
- OH, MAN,
I FORGOT THE PI.
YEAH!
- AHH!
OH...
- OH, MAN,
I MEAN, YOU KNOW...
THAT--THAT, MAN...
THAT--THAT...
THAT COULD BE
A ROCKET SHIP,
OR--OR
A LIGHTHOUSE.
NAW, MAN, YOU STRAIGHT UP
GOT A [bleep] ON YOUR CHEST.
- AHH!